I need to have you all here on this
wonderful day in New Orleans
this is an unusual panel we are going to
talk about feature writing but as a
genre that perhaps offers more than just
you know what you read in section b of
the daily paper let me take a second if
you would and introduce my fellow
panelists here some of whom may be more
familiar to you than others preceding
simply in alphabetical order
Kevin Allman is our local boy kevin is
the editor of gambit weekly which is our
extraordinary alternative weekly
newspaper here in New Orleans Kevin his
work has appeared in The Washington Post
in the Los Angeles Times The Globe and
Mail in Canada and our own Times
Picayune as well as details Vogue and
other publications around the country
interestingly particularly for the
purpose of this panel he's also a member
of the National Book Critics Circle a
novelist the title of his recent novel
was tight shot which was nominated for
an Edgar Award by the Mystery Writers of
America and he was also the winner of
the 2008 Walker Percy southern
playwrights festival so he's a man who
lives in many genres
also with us today coming in from New
York is Katherine fountain who was
actually on the program in the festival
I believe yesterday for a panel for the
master class she is the deputy editor of
The New York Times Magazine or was the
deputy editor from 1998 until just this
past October and she's now the books and
theater editor on the daily New York
Times himself there are previous jobs at
the Times included being deputy editor
of the book review deputy science editor
of The Times and senior editor of the
magazine which again makes her
especially appropriate for talking with
us today on this topic Chris Hedges was
apparently elusive at the New York Times
with it for many years but mostly
serving in overseas capacities he was a
foreign correspondent for nearly two
decades for The Times also for
the Dallas Morning News the Christian
Science Monitor and National Public
Radio he was a member of the team that
won the 2002 Pulitzer Prize for
explanatory reporting as opposed to the
other kind of reporting I suppose which
is simply obstacle
ne and in addition he's the author of
the bestseller American fascists and the
National Book Critics Circle Award
finalists for the war is a force that
gives us meaning and most recently for a
book published by Simon & Schuster
when atheism becomes religion so thank
you all for joining us here in New
Orleans at the Tennessee Williams
literary we've been tasked today with
talking a bit about feature writing as a
genre in the previous panel you might
have heard in the characterization that
northerners will give you information
but southerners will give you a story
and feature writing perhaps is the
Very's onra that falls in between those
two areas a genre that is published in
newspapers and magazines ostensibly to
convey information but on the other hand
offers a great deal more potential let
me let me cast it this way is feature
writing particularly with the
contraction and the decline of daily
newspapers around the country
what is the role today what is the
nature of feature writing as a genre and
what what promise does it offer us that
that more conventional journalism like
not any of you want to start that off as
the editor here surrounded by writers
roll of feature writing this is gonna
remain strong I think the reason sorry
the reason newspapers exist is to
disseminate news but I think a lot of
the reason that people read newspapers
and especially magazines even news
magazines is for an understanding of not
only the news but the news in a broader
sense cultural news sociological news
and what you said before about a story I
think is always relevant in feature
writing and so I think that people also
just enjoy the narrative element of
feature writing and as long as
newspapers exist in some form maybe not
an on paper as we now read them but in
some form that feature writing has a I
I would hope has a good future I think
it's appreciated form they appreciate it
for Kevin you're also an editor as well
as a writer what's your sense of it my
sense of it is that nobody knows where
it's going right now it'll always be
around but in what form yeah there's no
telling probably the the mid part of the
20th century was probably the Golden Age
for that when people would sit down and
read a five thousand six thousand word
story that had a strong narrative and
all of that there were hundreds of
magazines that would publish those
things there were advertisers that would
support them and now we're looking at I
mean the Christian Science Monitor
folded Friday went online only Time and
Newsweek I doubt that they'll both be in
existence by the end of next year and
what really scared me was at the New
Yorker in one of its January issues was
down to ten pages of advertising and you
know they're dumping subscriptions you
can get a subscription to The New Yorker
for $24 for 52 issues so I'm not sure
what form it's gonna take people always
going to want to do it but right now the
crystal ball is really cloudy I think
part of the decline of newspapers and
and you can see it in sort of how
Phin local papers have become has taken
a tremendous toll on two aspects of
reporting one investigative reporting
and the second is feature writing and I
think the cause is the same these are
both very labor-intensive and
time-consuming activities I began as a
reporter now almost three decades ago
and have watched the arc of that decline
throughout my career and I think that
without doubt it is harder and harder to
find good writing in American newspapers
a good writers have been shot at aside
the quality of the writing has
deteriorated markedly and I fear as you
do where that's going to go I mean those
of us who can publish books I think have
tried to keep alive our love of literary
journalism but there are as you point
out very very few outlets now I mean
we're all sort of competing for a
handful of publications places like
Harper's for instance where as two
decades ago there were dozens I want to
revert to my optimistic future which is
that I think you're both right that
traditional media as as we know them and
read them and hold them in our hands are
declining and certainly the two areas
you talked about our labor intensive and
expensive for to foot the bill for oh
sorry okay that basically what I said is
the traditional media I agree is in
decline but I think that online media is
really really a thriving area and I
think even that some of the traditional
media have very strong online components
and but there are also a lot of
independent online magazines that are
publishing really good things Slaton
salon I think are the best known of them
but and it kind of depends on how we
define feature writing if you
include personal essays and political
essays
I think certainly they're thriving but I
also think that just online media is
opened up a lot of area for good writing
that the decline of newspapers may be
shutting off let me respond to that I I
I think the problem with online media is
that they've not attracted the
advertising base that supports that kind
of work that allows a great writer like
Gay Talese to go out to Hollywood and
spend six weeks day in and day out
writing that classic story Frank Sinatra
had a cold it is extremely time
consuming and costly to do it and we see
with newspaper websites the New York
Times website is of course a wonderful
website but it only attracts I believe
nine or eleven percent of advertising
revenue and that's true for all
newspapers large and small the
advertisers have not migrated from
newsprint to the site and I think we
also have to be clear in understanding
that new media configurations impose
their own demands on content the average
reader of the New York Times spends with
a paper edition about 45 minutes with
the paper the average viewer of the New
York Times website spends about seven
minutes they use the website the same
way they use CNN or Google News or
anything else to get headlines they're
not actually reading and I think that
for those of us who are readers anything
that runs over 1,500 words I'm and I'm
sure I'm not alone I have to print it
out there that your eyes become
exhausted trying to read through a
complex and textured narrative online so
I'm not as optimistic I think that that
the internet imposes its own demands in
the same way that we saw television
imposed
demands on how content is shade I'm not
as optimistic either and I'll give an
example right now as an editor I've been
wanting to send a rider down to united
Hama nation which is down at the Gulf of
Mexico and it's American Indian
community that was impacted very hard by
Hurricane Gustav and Ike and
tremendously under-covered by the media
in better times I might be able to send
down a rider four to three weeks to get
to know the people and to spin a
narrative that becomes a feature story
that tells the larger story through the
eyes of of the people who went through
it I don't have that money or that time
or that space now so if I send someone
down it's going to be for two or three
days they're gonna be doing a lot of
research on the internet beforehand
going down with a lot of preconceptions
and bringing back what's gonna be more
of a less of a feature and more of a
hard news story when it might be better
told as the story of human beings and
not as the story of wetlands being
washed away and all that so what you
were saying about investigative
reporting I think is very true we don't
have the time or the money or the space
for that anymore in many newspapers and
magazines and that's sad well this
conversation is taking a very
interesting direction in pointing to
among other things the technological
changes especially the internet and
there are financial ramifications Chris
mentions the the contraction of
advertising dollars in the web page of
the New York Times for example let me
roll us back a couple of decades just to
frame this a little bit because Chris
mentioned gay talese in the 60s and in
the 70s the so-called new journalism was
probably the greatest flourishing of the
genre feature writing that journalism
has seen in this country if you think
back for example to Jack Newfield and
the Village Voice of Tom wolf an
electric kool-aid acid test and as well
as a series of other works of new
journalism before he turned intresting
lead to fiction
Esquire magazine along with the Village
Gay Talese often wrote for them this was
an extraordinary moment it then started
to bend and metamorphose itself you had
the sort of redheaded stepchild of the
New Journalism gonzo journalism which
became even more participatory
particularly as practiced by Hunter S
Thompson in Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas for instance in which the
journalists not only embedded himself in
the story such as Kevin was just talking
about assigning a writer to do but in in
the hands of Hunter s Thompson the the
reporter became the story and became the
actor on his own stage so let's just
frame back for just a little bit of a
few decades because it's not that long
ago what was it that led the New
Journalism or enabled the New Journalism
to become really the premiere genre in
this country I would I would argue that
it virtually superseded even fiction in
the national consciousness and in the
literary community for about a decade or
decade and a half Oh
Rolling Stone was it was another venue
for tremendous journalism Joe Eszterhas
before he started writing screenplays
was a really terrific new journalist so
what was it that made that kind of
feature writing as as dominant as
compelling and powerful and and what has
changed let me there's also a cultural
dimension to all of this we live in an
image based society and the decline that
you mentioned is part of our
transformation from illiterate culture
to an illiterate culture forty-two
million Americans are functionally
illiterate another roughly 50 million
are semi-literate meaning they read at a
fourth or fifth grade level that's
almost a third of the country and those
people who are technically literate even
people who have college degrees opt into
an illiterate culture they stop reading
and you see it in terms of the decline
of print based material a across the
cultural spectrum you see it in the
publishing industry you see it with
magazines you see it with newspapers 80%
of American households last year did not
buy a book and so much of what we're
going is a very frightening cultural
transformation where we believe I think
of course this is a an illusion that we
can receive information through images
the two political campaigns that we just
went through for president were based on
personal narrative and how we were made
to feel they were not fundamentally
based on ideas and that confusion of
propaganda with ideologies that belief
that how we you know how we are made to
feel is a form of knowledge I think as
has been has been as destructive as
perhaps anything else that has a gripped
our culture since I as you correctly
point out this heyday of of literary
nonfiction in the 60s and 70s
Catherine or Kevin well to attempt to
answer your question about what gave
rise to New Journalism I that was too
young to actually really be aware of the
shift when it came except that I was a
reader and I don't know where it came
from but I I would argue that we're
going through a concurrent kind of shift
right now was moving out from these
traditional magazines that we're talking
about I mean I agree Esquire Rolling
Stone the New York Times Magazine where
I worked for ten years you know they're
all publishing pretty good stuff still
but if you really really want to read
interesting material it's on other kinds
of subjects I am in my master class
yesterday or
people in that to read the best American
magazine writing the thing that the
National Magazine Awards to as me puts
out every year it's full of amazingly
really great writing but it's being
published in places that you probably
haven't heard of and magazines like seed
and it's the only one I can think of off
the top of my head but there's a great
piece in that magazine it was published
in seed I mean in the book form of it so
I do think that now the by necessity we
a feature writing is kind of seeing also
a change maybe not as traumatic and
maybe not as lasting as the rise of New
Journalism and maybe that was just
because there happened to be a number of
really really spectacular writers coming
to maturity at that point and some
really brilliant editors certainly you
know the editors at Esquire Rolling
Stone made an enormous difference in
their rise of that kind of journalism
now I think it's more the shift is more
a response to the necessity for a shift
but to me it's producing some pretty
good stuff so Kevin what's your take on
this we're all so cheerful here today
are not the most depressing the channel
I've ever seen is George still president
that you know the right that I miss
something okay um I I think there's a
couple of things one one is that we
don't we don't have kind of a national
media bonds that we used to I mean a
cover story in Time magazine 50 years
ago would be the talk of various social
classes various races not meanness this
would bind the country same thing with
the nightly news and Walter Cronkite and
huntley-brinkley and all that what was
said there was shared among a vast
variety of Americans we don't have that
anymore it's now it's everything's on
cafeteria plan um so you pick the news
that you want to watch and it's usually
the news that reinforces your own
preconceptions about the world whether
it's Keith Olbermann or Sean
ready you pick the radio that you want
you pick all these things none of that
is conducive to feature writing to
feature journalism which by necessity
tells a story somewhat akin to fiction i
I mean I can't even really think of a
I'm trying to think of something in the
last 10 years somewhat feature story
that had everybody in the country
talking well I think you're touching on
the very thing let me jump back one step
even further prior to the New Journalism
in the 60s and 70s the period that I
would argue in which American journalism
flourished was much earlier and was they
were called the muckrakers people like
Lincoln Steffens and Ida Tarbell and you
may recall and it took a literary form
also enough than Sinclair's the jungle
and what they were doing was writing
about industrial conditions they were
writing about social conditions and what
these two periods of flourishing a
feature writing had in common I'm going
to toss this out as a hypothesis is
these were moments of great political
tumult when the status quo was being
challenged by a progressive labor unions
in the early part of the century and the
rise of socialism before it was
frightened underground by the Red Scare
and then its resurgence during the
Vietnam War and the civil rights
movement and ultimately the feminist
movement as well and feature writing
seems to take its heart and gets its
pulse rate racing when it has something
to engage with that means something that
changes lives
when it's not just entertainment and
it's more than just a coincidence that
that is when future writing seemed to
have so much heart and so what I'm going
to ask here is is is that part of what
happened in the in the 90s have under
the era of George Bush and not not to be
overwhelmingly partisan and lay it all
at his
or a lot of these problems the economics
undermining the major newspapers and
magazines certainly pre-existed George
Bush but can I say this is no defense of
George Bush but the media was really
shitty when it came to covering what
George Bush did really really bad I mean
we look back and and I mean no offense
to the New York Times but you know I'm
sure you had nothing to do with that but
and and I guess I don't entirely agree
with you Michael because one of the best
pieces of feature writing that I
remember in the last ten years was Dan a
priest in the Washington Post who gate
and the post gave her the time and the
resources and the support to do the
Walter Reed Medical Center expose and I
think it took nine months and tens of
thousands of dollars and that made a
difference that was something that I
think everybody in this room remembers
and talks about and all that that was
the last piece of really good feature ID
and she used the stories of the soldiers
and she's the stories of the nurses and
she's the stories of the bureaucracy and
just pulled out a hell of a piece of
journalism part of what I think that the
landscape has changed I mean you're
certainly right about the muckrakers and
about the new journalists in the 60s
that there was a kind of passion which i
think is extremely healthy and something
that established news organizations like
the New York Times deal with very
uncomfortably but the fact is the the
broad mass of the literate culture
turned to print organizations print
mediums in order to get their
information and that has changed
profoundly you know we rely now on
primarily electronic conveyors of you
know information and most all of these
are corporatized I mean the there are
about six
or eight companies Viacom Rupert
Murdoch's News Corp Disney General
Electric the control just about
everything except for some of these very
marginal publications and a few
community radio stations that we see
hear or read and the bottom line of the
corporate of corporate entities is
profit and it is about the lowest common
denominator and it is about appealing to
everybody and it is about not angering
their advertising base I think we're all
talking about different things here I
don't I think first of all I don't think
Daenerys
what she wrote was feature writing and
you know it was it was investigative
journalism written large and I don't
think newspaper writing for the most
part is feature writing to me I mean
maybe we should all define what we think
feature writing is to me feature writing
is is a way to address a subject that
may have something to do with the newest
but in which essentially what you're
doing is telling some kind of story that
is behind the story and telling it in a
narrative way it can appear in a
newspaper there certainly you know kinds
of future writing that do appear in
newspapers but to me primarily feature
writing is this magazine writing it it
it can become book writing a lot of
magazine pieces become book writing but
I don't know do you I mean why did you
mention down a priest does feature
writing it's because this is the closest
thing I could think to it to some to an
organization that would actually devote
the time and money that would go into
something akin to feature writing
because I think that is the main problem
now you know unless you're Yan winner
who's gonna pay Matt Taibbi to travel
around the country to do these you know
kind of Nouveau Hunter s Thompson pieces
unless you have that kind of backing
financially and
in your gut you're not gonna get good
feature writing I I do think a lot of
magazines are still you know backing
reporters to go out and spend some time
I know the New York Times magazine
you know we're not gonna send somebody
to travel around the country for two or
three months but we'll send somebody to
or at least we would up till this year I
don't think we're sending anybody
anywhere now to Central America to
report a story or to give them the time
to reach for a story over a period of
time not a whole lot more money to do it
but certainly the time to do it and the
and the expense money to travel to two
or three different places and I think
other of these dying major magazines
still also do that I think that very
they're very few I mean you know the the
you know we can sit here and just start
ticking off you know they're there the
landscape is so diminished I mean you
can't argue that's just factually true
yes you're right the New York Times
magazine will still do stuff and the New
Yorker but these smaller magazines like
seed I can I I don't know the magazine
but I'm pretty certain they don't have a
budget that they can hand somebody
thousands of dollars to go off for weeks
and do this kind of work and it it takes
that kind of time and it takes those
kind of resources in order to produce
something of that quality I don't know
seems budget either so well but again if
you think and if we are suggesting that
the economics and in this battle between
the the business office and the
editorial office in American journalism
goes back to the inception of journalism
itself I mean these debates were going
on in the early 19th century in
newspapers and yet at some point and and
I would suggest it was often through
alternative presses you know Kevin
you're the editor of the alternative
weekly here and one of the reasons that
newspapers like The Village Voice
Chicago Reader the thenat
who are all hosed financially right now
who are what oh you know the creative
loafing which has a chain is applying
for bankruptcy The Village Voice is a
husk of what it was you know we're we're
it's great to say alternative but
they're just not making the pills but
cheerful again well sometimes it's from
its from the the slough of despair that
ultimately you know we emerge and Andrea
rise
I really didn't plan on taking this
direction in this conversation I was
really feeling pretty cheerful myself
before this whole conversation began you
may please
because they can't afford it so they
welcome me in with open arms and I'm
sorry but I'm tired of hearing all the
negativity well it's not a matter of its
but it's not a matter of being negative
or you know being a pessimist or an
optimist I mean I was a war
correspondent for most of my life and
people who didn't very quickly grasp the
reality of the landscape around them
often didn't live very long it's a
matter of looking at the factual data
that as kevin has pointed out is deeply
disturbing about media alternative media
that we all care deeply about and that
have been such an important element in
American democracy in providing
alternative voices about it's just true
I mean they are you know and Kevin just
talked about the Phoenix and the voice
and go to New York and pick up the voice
and and pick up with the voice as to
what it was which is a local paper by
the way I mean it's an alternative local
paper so right well the for those of us
who write for magazines
it's just indisputable that the outlets
that we have are diminished and those
that remain are really hanging on by
their fingertips I mean that's just a
fact and for those of us who care about
writing and see and not just as a kind
of art form or a passion but believe I
think I'm as I'm sure all of us do at
this table that it is an absolutely
essential element it's one of the
pillars of our democratic society that
this isn't just about the decline of
newsprint or the decline of magazines or
the decline of feature writing I you
know remaining in a print-based society
and a print
based cultures allows a populace to deal
with ambiguity with nuance with
complexity with other points of view
instead of being fed these thought
terminating cliches that are pumped out
over the airwaves on this this has an
existential element to it that is deeply
important for the maintenance of our
open society here's one of the ironies
particularly look at to the QA and a
little bit okay give us just a few more
minutes okay I got to earn their honor
area the ironically we were talking to
southern culture was the topic of the
previous panel and Rick bragged for
example one of the great practitioners
of the southern story talks about that
oral tradition because his people from
northern Alabama a in fact don't read
and thus the oral tradition become
became dominant and was a very important
device for cultural continuity for
shared values and for commentary but
here's the irony it seems to me in our
contemporary culture in this mate
this may illuminate what why feature
writing is threatened we have a new form
of oral culture what is supplanting
print journalism is television talk
shows the pundits the Sean Hannity's you
know and and and people of that ilk but
it's it's instantaneous it's off the top
it's not reflective it's not
investigative and I'm not even going to
you know it I don't think we even want
to go in the direction of the extreme of
this new form
Rush Limbaugh which is the very worst
example of it but what has happened
culturally if we think of the
implications of this is we're bombarded
with information daily there's a dozen
of these men and women on TV every
single day chattering away at us
blathering away at us but how what does
it say about a culture that is now moved
from being a literate culture in which
long
deliberative investigative pieces have
been sir planted by just instantaneous
and daily chatter and I think Chris it's
a little bit of the what you were
talking about in terms of the political
implication there was a great book
written in the early 50s by the British
social critic Richard Hogarth called the
uses of literacy in which he saw a lot
of this coming and he he understood that
the creation of mass culture meant the
destruction of another culture which was
oral culture it replaced oral culture
and he wrote it at the perfect time in
which he was able to document that
destruction among the working class in
England and so the you're very right
that we have a new national narrative a
common vernacular built primarily around
trash talk and celebrity gossip and
trivia which has corroded and infected
news is passed off as news so that we
are not only entering an image-based
world an image-based culture one that is
essentially post literate but we are
destroying those that the the the the
the viewpoints the expressions the
distinct individuality and I think one
could argue even the complexity of human
life by eradicating the power of both
our literate and our oral culture this
would certainly be Hogarth's argument I
think he was on to something I can't
argue with any of that I mean I the rise
of charge TV is devastating for public
discourse but I don't think it really
has much to do with feature writing I
think uh to go back to where I started I
do think there's a
very very strong new forum for future
writing and that is basically online
journalism you may print it out but it's
still there and it's still is journalism
that is is produced there's and
disseminated without all the traditional
hindrances that are now you know
affecting newspapers which is the cost
of paper the cost of ink the cost of
trucking the cost of distribution and I
think that actually there's a very very
thriving community of writers and
readers online I mean you need to know
that where to look for them I don't
think there's a mass readership for
anything but I actually don't think
there's ever been a mass readership for
anything I'd love to know how many
people actually read the jungle you know
I mean maybe it seemed like everybody
was talking about it but my guess is oh
no I'm sure we've all read the jungle
but I mean I I think it it there we
think back to things that everybody was
talking about but really those everybody
we're probably as you know sort of small
group as everybody is today
and I I think that we are evolving into
we're not there and certainly the
advertising model isn't there and if
can't be paid for in the end it's not
gonna thrive but I think they're gonna
figure it out and I I do think that you
know my kids generation I'm a 25 year
old son this is spirit literate and he
does almost all his reading online and I
don't think that's so unusual these days
I think and I think he's really really
interested in reading and I think a lot
of kids aren't katherine lee assisted
the is possibly the relationship between
feature writing as you yourself intuited
a few minutes ago in response to Kevin
much of the feature writing we've been
discussing has actually tended not all
that the Rolling Stone not necessarily
but much of it it's also been close to
investigative journalism one of the
great strengths of
alternative weeklies the ones that we
mentioned which are now very much in
jeopardy was the investigative
journalism that they were doing or the
cultural commentary that they were doing
which the mainstream press would not
well they are the mainstream press these
days whether they want to admit it or
not say they've been around 50 plus
years of the our mainstream okay
now they've obtained a degree like James
Agee writing about the worst thing that
can happen in let us now praise famous
men the worst thing that can happen to
an artist is social acceptance that that
art art thrives on it's marginality this
may be why the Southern tradition is so
rich we certainly thrive on our
marginality in that regard but I don't
think this is an incidental coincidence
in all seriousness the New Journalism
and and the muckrakers both both but
those two periods had in common is they
they were investigative they were also
very politically conscious and they wore
alternatives they tended to be driven by
ideologies that were counter to the
prevailing here's one of the interesting
thing about the New York Times if you
ever study the structure of journalism
this goes back to where feature writing
diverges from traditional journalism New
York Times is very interesting
institution ever notice that how many
articles on the front page New York
Times say special to the New York Times
right as if it has an elevated status
and as a privileged status and obtaining
information that nobody else can one of
the other interesting devices if you
study patterns of journalism the new
york times more than any publication
relies on unnamed highly placed sources
if you were to go through the New York
Times and look at the number of articles
that don't quote a source and that rely
on that privileged access now this leads
to certain abuses you may recall during
the Vietnam War this led to a
highly-placed a source in the
administration referring to the absolute
brilliance of the policies of Henry
Kissinger in navigating
the FM war the highly placed source
commenting on dr. Kissinger was dr.
Kissinger but it had to do with the
structure of the journalism itself now
feature writing one of the things that
made it different is it had a very clear
individual voice and the reporter the
writer of it whether it was in the old
period a Lincoln Steffens or Jack London
before he turned to fiction or during
the New Journalism carry a Tom Wolfe 400
Thompson they had a voice and the
journalist himself was an active agent
Jack Newfield and writing for the
Village Voice always in his articles
revealed the news gathering process
itself he demystified it he talked about
picking up the phone and talking to the
deputy mayor right
he didn't it wasn't a highly placed
source privileged only to the Village
Voice it was Jackie O field picking up
the phone and talking to the deputy
mayor and embedded in the very structure
of the journalism and the genre was the
news gathering process and it didn't
mystify a very much revealed itself so
let's see if we can come back around the
the charge we had in coming on this
panel was to talk about how feature
writing was distinct from other forms of
journalism and maybe maybe this will
help clarify because Katherine you you
I heard that plaintive cry before what
are we all talking about who are some of
the best examples of feature right there
are times you're gonna pick up okay
there's a Dueling oak in Central Park
sources are allowed to remain anonymous
perhaps more often than they should be
The Times reporters are our rules of
conduct are that with an anonymous
source the editor has to know who they
are and the editor asks and is always
told who they are the kinds of stories
that anonymous sources appear and where
they don't need to appear actually
happen to be feature stories for the
most part where you know somebody just
doesn't want to be named for some reason
because just want to be a public figure
I think
with news stories where anonymous
sources appear and by the way when that
happens in future stories so we have our
equal ID public editor who will haul
anybody up on that and does repeatedly
Crispin talked to this more than I can
because he was a news reporter for a
long time but there are a lot of new
stories that you just simply won't get
unless you guarantee somebody anonymity
and that's why those things continue to
exist there's a kind of tension because
as Kathryn points out correctly there
are moments when you must turn to an
anonymous source I can tell you having
covered conflicts that literally by
naming certain people in a story they
could be killed and I've even
interviewed during though I covered the
war in El Salvador for five years I
would many times interview illiterate
campesinos who would give me their name
but the kinds of things that they were
telling me I understood would put their
life in jeopardy either by the military
or by the FMLN which was not a rebel
movement which would occasionally carry
out executions of people that they
considered to be pro-government and
territory they controlled so I wouldn't
print their name the tragedy is that you
have reporters Judy Miller would be a
perfect example who abuse that I think
important aspect of news gathering and
she of course anonymously quoted Lewis
Scooter Libby to publish falsehoods in
the New York Times and then staged a
little soap opera where she went to jail
to in essence defend somebody who had
leaked the name of Valerie plane and in
a kind of retribution against her
husband who had been a whistleblower so
it really boils down to the ethical
composition of the reporter and I think
that's why you know
ethics are so important within
journalism but there has to be a place
for the anonymous source because many
people within institutions I mean it's
know that when I covered El Salvador
again during the Reagan administration
the death squads were killing between
eight hundred and a thousand people a
month and there were members of the
State Department in the embassy in San
Salvador who leaked to the press
informations about government complicity
with the desk watts and that information
was important for the American public to
understand this was at a time when
Congress had to certify every six months
continuing aid and it created a kind of
pressure until finally there was an
active part in the US government to shut
the desk wads down and so this the
tragedy is that this is an extremely
important ethical responsibility on the
part of the reporter and it has the
capacity to be misused and it has been
misused it was misused by Michael Gordon
and Judy Miller in the build-up to the
war in Iraq and it's a terrible stain on
the New York Times which is flawed as
all institutions are flawed but then
there are also many examples where I
think it has been used correctly to the
the betterment of our common good into
the society at large there is also I
would defend it in a lot of kinds of
feature writing as well I think if
you're writing about children in a lot
of cases you simply I mean if it's a
child who
some kind of a disability mental
disability or we once did a story in the
magazine about a high school junior high
school kid who was a crossdresser nobody
in his school knew he was a crossdresser
it was a really interesting feature
story um that said a lot about what was
then kind of an evolving phenomenon if
we had named that kid that he would have
been lynched in his in his middle school
I mean it was it was that or or no story
what times does however is even though
they'll disguise a name in feature
writing in and news reporting you're
never allowed to use anything that is
not in some way accurate if we use
initials they have to be the initials
that are the person's actual initials if
we don't use the name at all if we use a
descriptive term it has to be something
like you know that is an accurate
description
we don't allow conflation of two
different characters into one Judy
Miller
basically I think is responsible for the
enormous distrust that people have
newspapers right now and and that's a
tragedy
I can't recover from in the interest of
full disclosure I am a lifetime
subscribers in the New York Times and it
was but it's hard to come back from
something like that just as it was from
you know our previous scandal yeah I was
really trying to turn in raising that
issue of different styles and structures
of types of journalism I was trying to
get us back to the question of what
characterises feature writing and the
reason I brought up anonymity in a story
was to contrast it with the very
personal voice of some of the stronger
pieces of New Journalism we've got a few
minutes left for the panel to talk
before we can toss it open to questions
from the audience who are me Kevin you
wanted to say let's talk about future
writing this is the probably the best
feature writing I've read and maybe the
last two years was a piece by a woman
named Nancy
woman who's written for some new york
publication she's in Portland Oregon and
she doesn't work much because she needs
to feel that pull to get into these
things but in Portland there was a case
of a terminally ill child that had
tremendous support from the community
mother completely devoted to her every
year one Peter or Paul from Peter Paul
and Mary would come to town and they'd
do a concert and raise money and this
child had everything wrong with her and
after Peter or Paul left that night
child was about 14 the mother put a lot
of sleeping pills and the daughter's
nightly medication took sleeping pills
herself and they went to bed together
and died and this was on all front page
of the Oregon II and this was on the
front page this was on top of the news
of what a tragedy this was and Nancy
thought there was something fishy about
the story and she went and she dug and
when she came up with his an amazing I
think it's about 3500 word story about a
child that wasn't sick and it was a case
of Munchausen's by proxy and she went
and she send the child it supposedly had
had all these injuries and surgeries and
all that stuff and she saw the corpse
and there wasn't a cut on it and it was
just an amazing piece of future
journalism that not only blew away would
have been done before but also brought
her Nancy into the story as a mother and
who could do something like this and why
and I still remember it ending with her
I mean she obviously I wouldn't say
fictionalized it but imagine what that
last few minutes would be like of a
child that was used to taking medicine
every night giving her the last minutes
that she'd ever take and then setting
the scene with the police found in bed
which was the two curled up together and
that was an extraordinary piece but I
think it took about six months to do and
she didn't make a damn dime off of it by
the time I was done I mean it was
hundreds of hours of work and she
probably got a couple thousands of
dollars for it but um that's the kind of
thing that I would like to see more of
but I just don't even when you write as
I do for a magazine like Harper's which
will pay roughly a dollar a word
and expenses by the time you're done
you're working for minimum wage
especially if you go overseas the
logistics the writing the editing the
reporting so when we talk about the
glory days of feature writing when you
put that kind of work into it nobody's
getting rich you know these are our
labors of love and and I think that what
I hear especially Kevin saying in which
I concur with is that now even that
minimal financial backing to carry out
this kind of work is disappearing and
you know we all have to pay the rent we
all have to go to the grocery store
there are just hard facts
I mean writers don't make a lot of money
there are just hard facts about
existence that while we certainly will
try and continue to do it is making it
harder and harder and harder
tell us speaking of trying to help a
writer make a little more money tell us
a little bit about your most recent book
when atheism becomes a feature writer
can make more money as you say having I
live off of my books I mean and and I'm
fortunate um you know a lot of writers
can't I'm you know several of my books
have sold extremely well so I can
between giving college lectures and
advances I can survive it's a precarious
existence but it does allow me to do
what I want to do the book on the
atheism is a little it's not feature
writing it I graduated from seminary at
harvard divinity school I wasn't
ordained but I finished all the academic
work and when I came back from my time
overseas had watched how the Christian
Right had moved from the margins of
American society under the Bush
administration of the very epicenters of
power and spent two years writing a book
called American fascists the Christian
Right and the war on America
and then after that book came out when I
was a Fiat Sam Harris at UCLA and then
two days later I went to San Francisco
and debated Christopher Hitchens who
wrote God is not great at Berkeley not
an experience I would wish on anyone in
this room and it was it was an appalling
reaction I mean when I read through the
work and debated them to see how they in
the language of scientific rationalism
had replicated the very ideological
structures that I had just spent two
years writing about in the Christian
Right and look I graduated from seminary
at Harvard which I think has done more
than any other seminary in America to
produce atheists I I have a healthy
respect for atheism as a valid
philosophical thought all the great
reformers including Martin Luther and
Spinoza were not only denounced as
atheist but heretics but what we see
here is a new kind of fundamentalism and
so it's not a feature piece that's an
idea book and it and I you know that's
another panel but that's what prompted
me to write the book I came back just
furious the audience has been very
patient with us up to this point and I
thought I saw two people twitching
except except for you can't but that's
all right Debra okay are there any
questions that are burning within you
that you would like us to address there
is a microphone that it will be brought
around to you for the purposes of book
TV
yes ma'am they're in the back
microphones right next to you well then
they probably think they you do okay one
of those electronic media right exactly
actually that's sort of the drift of my
question I confess to being a little bit
surprised to hearing a couple of
nostalgic references to the good old
days when advertising supported good
journalism a little bit of a oxymoron in
my mind that's not exactly been a
marriage made in heaven over the years
is there no other way have you begun to
put any thought into how
we can in fact live off of or or sell
good writing without in fact making it
dependent to advertisers who are so
easily offended it's a very good
question
there was an article recently in
Newsweek magazine because I think
they're starting to examine themselves
about some of the new forms of
journalism wealthy individuals are
starting to support certain presses for
example the Nation magazine has long
been subsidized by wealthy supporters
Mother Jones magazine speaking of
another major alternative publication
has only been able to survive not by
advertising but by patronage The New
Yorker traditionally never made money it
may be now nobody's really sure but I'd
say from that January February whatever
that when that double issue was there
not Harper's always had you know money
behind a private money behind it I think
the Atlantic did I don't I mean I think
you're right I don't think that most
mainstream magazines at least were money
makers to Conde Nast magazines some of
them make money some of them don't
that's a reason that you know the New
Yorkers still published just because
Newhouse but the New York or some years
ago but even there were money makers
like Vogue which had a couple of
spin-offs they've now closed those
spin-offs down I don't know how
portfolio is doing I don't that was an
excellent question because in fact the
change that's occurring is moving more
towards a non profit model of
subsidization in order for these voices
to not be lost only if you use the
microphone
one of the things that's happening
because of the digital revolution if I
may and in other forms is the buying of
an individual song instead of an album
they're buying it and I think we're
gonna have to escape the notion that it
has to be published in a magazine or in
a the gambit which I love but that it
has to come in a big package like that
maybe individual pieces is the way to go
these publishers have looked into that
um in terms of making a micro payment
and they've even been talked about
taking the iTunes music store which now
sells videos and sells a whole bunch of
other things and trying to sell books
journalism on it I I don't know a part
of especially talking about feature
writing part it is serendipity um
and I and I think that's really missing
today is the idea of getting a big fix
Sunday paper and you want to read the
sports and you want to read this and
that but then you come across something
you never would have found on your own
and in the Internet age you never would
have stumbled on um and that would be
missing from that so if you're buying
something you already know you'll want
that would be fine
but trying to try to be led to something
you might not know that you'd be
interested in I'm not quite sure how
that works I think you do stumble on
things on the internet one thing leads
to another
oh I do too but I'm talking about paying
for things I mean you know but those are
free things that you link the bottom
line is that writers have to make a
living and you know you know we're
watching the death of metropolitan
dailies and Kevin's very right that
there's a democratic quality to these
publications and that you you pay for
stuff you didn't think about asking for
and find when a newspaper or magazine is
well edited and well-run that's part of
the you know opening up of new
experiences new ideas new stories new
information and as these large
publications let's say a newspaper like
the LA Times goes down it's not going to
be replaced
on the Internet even with all of the
downsizing at the LA Times 700 people
still work in the newsroom and no
internet site in LA is going to bring in
the advertising revenue for those
numbers so I think you're right that and
Catherine's right that there will be
these almost monastic type internet
sites that will seek hopefully to
preserve something of the tradition all
of us here care deeply about so that it
won't disappear but the idea that it can
be sustained or mainstreamed I think is
is in doubt I do think um even places
like the New York Times are I mean God
willing will survive as a news gathering
organization long after it survives as
the Sunday paper that drops on your
doorstep and that you pay a lot of money
for so I mean IIIi don't think the
internet can ever exist without the
major news organizations to provide the
material but I don't think that we
actually need to get those newspapers
anymore even though yes you may have
another question in the front row I
think here I'm a travel I'm a travel
writer probably one of the ultimate
feature writing types you know published
in magazines both the US and other
countries and to inject one positive
note my publications you know expect me
to write stuff that is non guidebook II
meaning they don't want some dim-witted
little dim witted little piece about ooh
here's a nice beach resort or something
you know they want me to my stories to
be experiential to have a plot to write
about quirky offbeat people I've
encountered write about an interesting
trend and I do but what I find is
interesting and this is a positive
development is that um I've known
writers who did trout a writing in the
80s and the
and they said back then they wrote all
these pieces about places they had never
been in other words you know their their
research was gleaned from books they
read movies they saw these were often
essay type pieces and I was actually
astonished to hear the back then that
was common and travel writing but the
writers guidelines of all my magazines
and some of my papers it even explicitly
says I mean we do not want guide book II
pieces those proliferate not only in
guidebooks but online where you know
stuff is just a long list of oh you know
restaurants hotels whatever but they
want me to tease out a real story you
know that would not be found in a
guidebook you know an interesting person
that you know typifies a place you know
a bizarre place to go you know what I
mean so that'd be good thing that you
know ages ago and travel writing people
are writing about places they had never
traveled to one one hopes that there are
no boring subjects there are only boring
writers and that by employing the sorts
of devices that you enumerated better
than any of us did by the way that was
very well done I thank you for that the
elements of future writing that you can
engage an audience there's another hand
way in the back if you want to run the
microphone over there give it just a
second for the purpose of we're all
slaves to the electronic media here hold
on it's coming commercial freedom yeah
this is electronic media be delivered on
foot so it's a little slower than usual
there you go okay so it wasn't worth the
wait
well let you know rather than see the
digital media as such a drawback I'm
thinking of the the disappearance so
much of the major television networks
and now we've got our alliterative cable
networks and we have digital areas where
I can listen to something as well as
read it is there any training going on
in the industry to have feature writers
take
advantage of alternative media rather
than just put the printed word on a
computer that could also sing to me or
play music along with a piece or show
pictures in rapid succession or slow
them down you understand where I'm
getting is there any movement in your
industry just as the historical fiction
writer life's changed when Google came
around they they had to adjust to that
to be a good fiction historical fiction
writers and if you like well we live in
a culture of moving images and that's
the problem you know having spent almost
two decades of my life outside the
United States I came back I had a kind
of Rip Van Winkle confrontation with my
own society and one of the things I
couldn't adjust to was how everything
moved and it that kind of constant
movement and change of image and scene
whether it's on the nightly news whether
it's on TV whether it's the bombardment
with advertising conspires against
thought and I used I moved back to New
York and I retreated into the
Metropolitan Museum of Art at least two
or three days a week because I could
stand before something that didn't move
and could think about it and absorb it
and find a texture to it and III think
that you know the the part of the
problem and part of the demise of a
literary culture is that we've
absolutely destroyed the pasta the
capacity for self-reflection and for
thought you know when when Proust wrote
in search of lost time
4,500 pages it was during an age when a
bourgeois man or woman would come home
and read and we to our detriment and
we're paying a cultural and a political
price for it we've obliterated that
within the culture and those I don't own
a
Lucian partly because I'm you know doing
everything I can to create walls for of
against that kind of intrusion because I
think at its core it's it's a way to
demolish self-reflection and
self-criticism which is what good
narrative writing and good reporting is
about and and and why those of us who
write books write books just I wanted to
mention I think the New York Times does
a great job with multimedia on their
website they've really figured out a lot
of ways to incorporate music and image
and all of these things along with the
traditional word and I wanted to get
that in there cuz I think the New York
Times takes a lot of crap for the sins
of just a few so but I think they've
done a wonderful job in multimedia I
don't really have anything to do with
the website but I actually agree with
you I think it's expanded your the
possibilities for what you're reading
you can read about in an art show and
see a slideshow to go along with it you
can read Mark Bittman telling you how to
you know do a complicated recipe and
then you can see Mark Bittman and a
little three-minute thing actually doing
the recipe for you and you can see a lot
of our foreign correspondents now carry
little mini recorders and so sometimes
you'll see an interview live some but in
a place where you would never dream of
being able to actually get such a
visceral sense of what's going on I
agree with you it's it's it's the one
part of the New York Times that is also
expanding and thriving financially so in
spite of the lack of advertising which
can't be denied but I think we might
have time for one more question all the
way in the back over on this side and
you get your exercise in with that
microphone watch out what you wish for
okay
okay yes ma'am hi this is about what you
think the potential is for writers to
become their own online publishers and
just a quick background of a magazine
writer the magazine not only folded but
the editors put their names on our
stories
what's the magazine I'm confronting them
with that I'd rather not be on book TV
but it's very uncool and I also write
for Huffington Post which is great
exposure but of course no money so I
lined up an advertiser sales rep and we
have a green online daily which
advertisers are coming on board and
that's exciting but do you think that's
the direction writers are gonna need to
go and it's become your own publication
can you name me one writer who just
writes online that makes his or her
living from marketing him ham rehearsal
well the new model would be you're also
the publisher and you bring on the
advertisers and you pretty I'm just here
talking about being Arianna Huffington
smaller
I think she's pure evil I think she's
absolutely exploitive I think she takes
the words of people who write for free
and sells ads around them and then
positions herself as some kind of
bullshitty progressive and that is
absolutely the wrong model for any young
writer to go into if you've got
something to write
don't give it to Arianna Huffington get
your own website do it for yourself and
you will get readers but don't give it
to Arianna I did start my own thank you
I'm in a second I'm gonna second that I
mean Kevin's dead on on that and and if
and you know that's why Huffington Post
is largely junk its celebrity driven
crap it's it is and if you've got a
famous name you can mix yourself up a
drink and and write your random thoughts
of the afternoon in the worst prose
possible and it'll be posted up there
with your picture and believe me for
those of us who care about writing which
is an all good writing is rewriting
whose sweat over every word who believed
in report
we know we talk about the internet the
bloggers are parasitic in the sense that
they don't report usually they don't
even pick up a phone they they feed off
of traditional news organizations to
then spin out their thoughts most of
which are insipid and for those luxury
with that but well for those of us I
don't a lot of them and and I think for
those yeah but a lot of what you read in
the daily paper is incipit - right but
but when you go out and report a story
you are giving another person a voice
and hopefully if you're doing it right
you're giving a voice to people who
without your presence would not have a
voice that's what great journalism is
about and and that almost never occurs
on the Internet reporting on the
Internet is about as common a phenomena
as blacksmithing
I'd like you to I hate to I think you're
painting to Bratislava I think reporting
on the Internet is a contradiction in
terms but I think that the Internet does
provide a forum for some pretty good
commentary and some pretty good
reflection and it's a pretty good
thinking kind of writing and I think you
can even see some of it on Huffington
Post it's true that they don't pay
anybody except the celebrities I believe
they certainly don't pay know they don't
pay the celebrities but Jamie Lee Curtis
does this for free to get her thoughts
on the Middle East on the other hand for
an aspiring for an aspiring writer who
creates their own blog it's fine it's
good but if that writer can also appear
on Huffington Post they're getting a lot
more readers and maybe it's the thing
that's going to help them be able to
move more into the kind of publications
that all of us would even the good
writers on the Internet of course there
are some and and I think that that
they're out there although I think the
mass of what's on the Internet is is not
good Chris the - supports in the
bookstore isn't good either
okay I agree with that I'm a total uh
tight I don't have agree with that I
mean it's not medium just because it's
the Internet I mean that there's crap in
every now I mean look at the knob look
at the publishing lists yeah sure I
fully agree and again that gets back to
the whole idea that this is something
that breaks through cultural boundaries
that this is a cultural deterioration
but I think that the the that what I
what I fear is that through all of these
changes with all of the many things
we're losing not just the physical news
print the the very ethical reporting
itself the ethic that drives good
journalism itself is under threat and I
don't see that ethic reported in the
Internet in fact it's the inverse you
you you write for a serious publication
or a newspaper it you work very hard as
a reporter to make sure it's accurate it
passes through the hands of editors
sometimes at a paper like the New York
Times to many editors but when you put
it into print it is as accurate and true
and careful as you possibly can be the
internet you throw anything out there
and then often and then if there's a
response sometimes maybe there's a
correction the ethic is completely
turned upside down on the internet and
that's a very important point to
remember that that that we're losing
many many things and one of one of them
is that that ethical engine that I think
drives good reporting in good journalism
I am very reluctant thank you thank you
very much
I'm very reluctant to have to bring this
panel to a close just when it is
starting to get even more interesting
please feel free to engage the panelists
in the lobby in the oldest of genre face
to face conversation